In today's video,
we are taking
a commonly despised item,
and making it
even more dangerous.
[Music]
Guys, we built
a random idea generator, and it
kicks out some weird stuff,
and some of them seem
like pretty mean ideas.
This time, it gave
us weaponized glitter.
Now, it doesn't go
into any details
about what that means,
it just leaves it up to us.
And so, we weaponized glitter.
Here's the basic idea.
Our random idea generator
told us to weaponize glitter.
So we're going to go
ahead and get creative with that
in a few different ways.
Namely, into really
really really really
adorable little bombs.
We've got three different
versions of weaponized glitter.
We've got some bombs
that are made
from glass Christmas ornaments
filled with glitter,
and painted to be super cute.
We've got Nerf darts
that we are dipping in glitter
and glue to make a sort
of DIY paint ball.
Although, it's more
glitter than paint.
And then we've got
water balloons full
of gelled alcohol, water,
and glitter, of course,
because that's the thing.
All right, on your mark?
Wait.
Get set!
First, let's show them
how we made these.
All right.
Well show you how we made these,
and then we'll show you
what they do.
So the first thing
that you want to do is assemble
all of your supplies.
Most of the stuff,
I got from a craft store.
So we've got glitter, a funnel,
different types of craft paint,
Model Magic, some craft cord,
and a piece of foam sheet.
Once you have the rest
of your supplies assembled,
you're going to want to get
a glass of Christmas ornament.
Now, you can choose what size
or shape you want.
I wanted to go with the very
classic looking video game bomb.
So I found the biggest
round ornament I could find.
So with these ornaments,
you can get them at pretty much
any store during Christmas time.
I was able to get
these on clearance,
because it's after Christmas,
but they're pretty simple.
They're made to fill
or to decorate.
So if you take off the top,
you're going to have
a little piece of wire
that we've clipped off,
and you're going to want
to save this top for later.
Next, you're going
to grab your funnel,
and you're going
to choose your weapon.
So I've got two different
colors of glitter.
So I'm going with
gold and for this one.
That's either going to look
like an awesome explosion,
or a Gryffindor party.
So for your next step,
you're going to add
a thin line of hot glue
right around the edge
of your glass ornament,
and we're going to put the lid
back on once that's in place.
Once your ornament is sealed up,
take a piece of your craft foam,
and cut a strip
that's about the same height
as the top of your ornament.
Once you've cut your strip
of craft foam,
glue it around the edges.
Probably go around it
twice to make sure it's
about the width and size
that you're going to want.
Next, you're going to take your
craft cord, and cut a piece,
maybe about 2 inches long.
Once you've got a decent
amount of hot glue,
we've almost formed the dome
at the top like a resin dome.
You're going to sink
your wick down into it.
[Music]
Once you've got
the body assembled,
you can start painting.
So the paint that I'm using
is not very expensive.
It's about 90 cents a bottle,
which is great.
But it also doesn't have
the best coverage.
So I'm going to probably
do two or three coats
of this black paint on the body,
but I'm going to be hitting it
with the heat gun,
so I don't have to wait
for it to dry.
If you use
a better quality paint,
you can probably
do this just once,
and not worry about it too much.
Once you've got the body
of your video game bomb
all finished painted,
you're going to want to hit it
with a layer of sealant.
This is probably my favorite
sealer I use for anything,
whether it's decorations
or cosplay.
This is Krylon Clear Sealer,
and it's amazing.
It works for anything.
[Music]
Alright, once you have
the base all made,
it's time to add the details.
And the way that we're going
to add the little face
and the feet is going
to be Model Magic.
It's super cheap,
super easy to use.
You don't need a whole lot
of skill or practice with it,
and it's going to form
really easy for what we need.
[Music]
Guys, I've already
assembled all of our bombs.
Now, it's time to make
some more weapons.
[Music]
That's still enough glitter
that you're not going
to want to get hit with it.
Any glitter is enough that I
don't want to get hit with it.
That's the point.
[Music]
All right, guys,
we've got three different types
of glitter weapons.
It's time for a field test.
[Music]
So glitter has a tendency
to stick to things forever.
And...
If you get it on you,
be prepared to have
it on you forever.
I'm trying not to
ruin my clothes.
I'm trying to ruin his clothes.
Yeah.
That's why they call it War.
Yep.
I've gone all out folks.
This is a head sock.
It's a rectangle
with a spot badly cut out
and sewn for your eyes.
[Music]
You're going down.
I'm yelling glitter.
Okay.
Yeah, I was having
that same problem.
And I say I was,
I mean, I still am.
This is going well.
This is glitter glue.
Now what we're doing
with this is
were actually coating the ends
of our Nerf darts in glue,
and then glitter.
And then we're shooting
each other with it.
[Music]
Bomb flower!
Bomb flower.
Your bomb didn't break.
No!
This is unfair.
Anybody ever play
Ocarina of Time?
Bomb flowers.
[Music]
3, 2, 1.
Nice.
[Music]
Hey Nate.
No.
I can't see.
They're sticking to you.
They're sticking to the gun.
I'm glittered.
You got me.
Wait, I've got water balloons.
[Music]
No.
No!
No! Don't move!
Aw.
I'm sorry.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
Am I covered in glitter?
Yeah, it's gold glitter.
Yes.
[Music]
I'm getting Mark, there.
Where's the other gun?
Aha, I got two bullets left.
Oh, no, guys.
I gotta go in.
I do it.
I gotta go.
Well.
[Music]
I'm on glitter.
What do you have in your hand?
Nothing.
What do you have?
Not a handful of glitter.
And dirt.
Oh, okay.
That's it.
Back off.
There's another balloon.
No, no, no.
No!
Okay.
No.
[Music]
Well, if you ever really
want to make somebody mad,
you can make your own
video game, Glitter Bombs.
I think the glue was a mean,
a mean addition.
I've never been so proud.
Guys, that was awesome.
But you know,
we've always got more
for you to see.
This box up here at the top will
take you to our latest video.
That box of the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Hit this bomb in the middle,
and it will subscribe
you to the channel.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see in the next one.
Talk to you then.